[Music]
after years of debate our divided
country has appeared to reach a
consensus in support of same-sex
marriage and the acceptance of gay and
lesbian people but these changes in
American culture have led to a growing
disconnect between public perceptions
and the actual experiences of LGBT
people perceptions of discrimination
against gay and lesbian people have
plummeted since 2013 particularly among
young adults
this stands starkly at odds with the
actual experiences of LGBT people so how
this happened there are a couple of
explanations first the focus by
activists in the media on same-sex
marriage simplified the more complex
views Americans have on LGBT issues
second opposition to gay rights is
increasingly absent from popular culture
and finally Americans have had greater
access to the lives of gay and lesbian
people through television and social
media than ever before as a result many
Americans are left with the impression
that we have reached a comfortable
consensus on gay rights do you think gay
and lesbian people face a lot of
discrimination in the u.s. let us know
in our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research of videos
from AI